So far we've seen two
complex types in Python.
We've seen the string type and
we've seen the list type.
Now, we're going to introduce
the dictionary type.
So there are many things that
are common between these three.
There are other things
that are different.
So to create a string we could have
a sequence of characters inside quotes.
To create a list we use
the square bracket, and
we can have a sequence of elements
inside the square bracket.
And the elements could be any type,
unlike a string where they
had to be characters.
So our string was
a sequence of characters.
Our list was a list of
any kind of value, so
a list of elements of any value.
The dictionary type.
We're going to create
using the curly bracket.
And the entries inside
a dictionary are key value pairs.
So here, I've created a dictionary
with two elements, and
each element, the key is a string.
Here's the string hydrogen, and
the value associated with that element,
is the number.
The keys in a dictionary can be any
immutable value, so they don't need to
be strings, they could be numbers,
they could be other things.
The values can be any value.
So what a dictionary is,
is that set of key, value pairs.
And the property that a dictionary
will give us is like the hash table,
that we can look up a key and
get the value associated with that key.
So one important property of all types
is whether they're immutable or mutable.
We saw that the string was immutable,
that means once we create a string,
we can't modify that string.
It has the same value, it always has.
A list was mutable, we can change
the values of elements in a list.
After we create the list,
we could append to the list,
adding new elements to it.
A dictionary is also mutable.
So after we create a dictionary,
we could add new key value pairs to it.
We could change the value of
values associated with keys.
We saw with strings, if s is a string,
then we can do s index i.
That will give us the ith letter and
string.
With list,
we can do something very similar.
If p is a list, we can do p index i,
to get the ith element of the list.
With dictionaries it's
a little bit different.
The syntax is the same,
we can do d index k.
With both strings and lists.
These were numbers.
Here the k is whatever the key value is.
So this is a key in the dictionary.
What d index k will give us
the value associated with that key
in the dictionary.
We'll see some examples soon.
We can also use our indexing and
assignments.
We saw with the list we could do this.
That would replace the value of the ith
element of p with whatever we have here.
With the string, we can't do that.
That produces an error.
And the reason we can't do it,
is because strings are immutable, so
there's no way to modify
characters in a string.
With the dictionary, we can,
and what the meaning of this,
is very similar to the meaning
of update in our hash table, so
that's equivalent to update the value,
the value associated with k to be v.